tu veux goûter mon sandwich se relever
si on récapitule thème pas mon sandwich
rosbif t'elle pas non plus ma musique
les gens qui se considère amis doivent
partager des choses peut être qu'on
devrait arrêter de l'être on devrait
arrêter d'être amis
alors qui fait exactement pareil oui on
bosse comme ça tout le monde le faire
face à la croatie journée a plutôt
trouvé mais faut croire qu'on n'a rien
en commun
après il mange ton sommeil puis paf en
maman elle a le droit d'être déprimé
merci la retrouvera jamais un mec aussi
bien que nick jamais sérieux d'où elle
sort cette [ __ ] de clarac personne
connaît après il vient paris comment ça
se fait que j'aie jamais entendu parler
d elle vient d'emménager à los angeles
est que les personnes ici donc tu t'es
dit avant de l'emmener au cha
initiateurs jeu devrait l'emmener voir
le pénis de nick salut tu es april et si
on allait se voir déchu comprends pas
pourquoi tu es aussi gentil avec moi au
moins ça nous donnerait une bonne raison
d'en coller lune qu'est-ce qu'ils sont
portés sur les fils d'abraham et
l'émission captive essayé d'ouvrir à
brocal de confusion côté rennais
quand tu compares famille ça une batte
de couy dit il n'a pas encore fait ça
avec moi
on devrait fixer des règles à notre
amitié
je suis d'accord
règle numéro 1 on parle jamais de numéro
deux on ne dit rien et tu vas pas tout
cas fait une balance benjamin tu sais ce
qui leur arrive au ballon ce sont les
flics anges tout sauvagement pendant
qu'elle dorme on désactive lors des
pectoraux de fumer la nuit en plein
milieu d'un ensemble on leur vole leurs
crèmes solaires espèce de petit rouquin
merde
eh ben c'est du joli
le meilleur ami traversier thema dégage
est en relation avec sexe ont toujours
la priorité sur les relations sans sexe
dans ce cas elle et moi on va devoir
serrer shiso je pense à toi tout temps
t'as pas assez fait preuve d'esprit
d'équipé l'aude coupe
je couche avec personne qui doit juste
une fille c'est parce que vous croyez